note e anote mesmo abatida e sabão aqui
não foi educado em casa vai ser tocado
por ano
ele só me bateu por fazer uma entrevista
de emprego
eu deixei as crianças com a vizinha ele
reclama da minha roupa se põe uma roupa
joãozinho não sou vagabunda seu próximo
batom vermelho ele fala que eu quero
aparecer
ele reclama da minha comida fala que a
europa todo dia a mesma coisa se você
não ficar comigo você não vai ficar com
mais ninguém eu vou te infernizar eu vou
publicar as nossas fotos íntimas em
redes sociais
eu vou te matar no começo parecia amor
que me amando assim vezes por dia
ele começou a controlar a minha vida
nessas todos os meus amigos da minha
família controlado os lugares que eu ia
os meus hábitos as roupas que usava
eu resolvi com o relacionamento ele não
aceitou
ele começou a me ameaçar ele me
perseguia na porta da minha escola ele
ficava na porta da faculdade me esperava
no meu trabalho
a última vez que nos encontramos ele
tentou enforcar
eu sugiro mas agora todo mundo sabe mas
casos como esses são corriqueiros no meu
dia a dia como promotora de justiça
atuando no combate à violência contra a
mulher
vocês devem estar se perguntando por que
resolveu ser promotora de justiça porque
ela defende os direitos da mulher porque
ela tá com essa roupa
essa toga é a prova que eu uso para
fazer júris de mortes violentas contra a
mulher
eu uso ela 12 anos e nunca vi um dia meu
filho me viu com essa roupa perguntou
mãe você criança sozinha você parece um
batman
naquele dia eu expliquei para ele a
mamãe vai para a sala de justiça
defendeu os direitos da mulher
se existe uma relação muito muito íntima
a minha avó a dona maria uma mulher à
frente do seu tempo
uma mulher de vanguarda
ela se separou muito cedo com quatro
filhos deve que a luta e venceu
transformar a dor em força e os índios
foi muito grudada nela que ela fazia de
tudo de forma diferente e aquilani
aguçava será uma certa curiosidade tudo
funcionava a cop-16 isso porque fez
aquilo o que você acha que eu devo ser
quando crescer
ela já que é tão questionadora gritando
você quer saber você tem que ser
promotora de justiça
eu cresci me formei estudo em quatro
anos e foi ser promotora de justiça
segundo lugar e no dia liguei pra ela só
passei mas em segundo lugar e ela
perguntou essa não vai lá questionado
quando passou em primeiro
a lei não dessa vez vou aceitar bem o
primeiro lugar eu comecei a trabalhar
como promotora de justiça foi embu-guaçu
carente mas com um dos maiores índices
de violência contra a mulher ficava numa
garagem em baixo de um prédio dos piores
crimes de violência
um dia chegou o meu filho está viciado
em cocaína
ele me bate todos os dias se eu não dou
dinheiro pra ele ele me bate ele ameaça
ele xinga e me perdi em casa
ele me ameaçou de morte eu realmente
estou com medo de morrer naquele dia eu
tinha nas mãos uma mulher com risco de
vida e do outro lado eu tinha uma das
melhores e maiores relações entre as
pessoas de mãe um filho mas nós tínhamos
que agir
conseguimos uma medida protetiva para
tirar uma cela do lar mas ele descumpriu
foi preso ficou dois meses preso e
nesses dois meses que ele ficou preso
atrás e lech e nasceu ela ia visitar a
promotoria mais gordinha começou a
pintar o cabelo de loiro ela me levava a
bordo
fubá quando marcelo foi so ela foi vista
nessa altura todos um feliz
ele melhorou agora ele já pode voltar a
morar comigo naquele momento eu senti a
sensação de dever cumprido e foi
promovida pela outra promotoria em
taboão da serra onde estou atualmente
dez dias depois do estágio era ligou
doutora eu tenho uma notícia pra dar pra
senhora a dona celeste e faleceu
o marcelo deu 20 facadas nela e matou a
própria daquele dia em diante a minha
vida e eu tive o firme propósito de
lutar pela vida das mulheres nós não
queremos perder mais vidas de mulheres e
eu percebi que eu tive que mudar a minha
atuação como a promotora de justiça
não se pensa em nada na promotoria
lutando por uma condenação que é
necessário mas não podia só cumprir o
meu dever
eu tinha que ir à lei e eu comecei a me
aproximar da comunidade e em escolas e
faculdades me aproximei dos movimentos
sociais das ativistas e atende muito eu
aprendi e nos crimes de violência contra
a mulher
a punição isoladamente não basta você
precisa olhar para a vítima e acompanhar
essa mulher
mas você também precisa olhar pro homem
está atrás de outra mulher e percebi
dois grandes motivos que fazem uma
violência aceitam essas trabalho no
brasil de um lado nós temos mulheres que
desistem muito denunciar
de outro lado nós temos homens e repetem
muito os seus comportamentos
o que libera o meu trabalho eu resolvi
trazer trabalho para essas mulheres
porque 27 6 por cento das mulheres não
têm condições econômicas de romper um
relacionamento sair num ciclo da
violência
eu fiz parcerias com órgãos públicos
empresas privadas para capacitar essas
mulheres inseridas diretamente
o trabalho da primeira empresa que
fizemos
levamos dez mulheres vítimas de
violência diretamente pelas abas
tudo bem que foi empresa do meu marido
mas já foi um começo
as mulheres estão em poder ada seus
homens atrás de uma mulher agredida em
um homem que agride e é com ele que eu
quero falar
aliás as mulheres vêem na promotoria de
justiça e fala doutora fala com ele não
susto nele ele é bom pai bom marido
penso eu não sou fantasma da susto
eu vou falar com ele sim mas de forma
institucionalizada
desenvolvemos um projeto para falar com
os homens que estão sendo processados
trazê-los para perto da promotoria para
acompanhar esse tempo que ele está sendo
processado ele não voltar a sair e
cometer outros crimes
nós temos hoje em dia 65% de
reincidências onde o trabalho 65 por
cento dos homens sayagred novamente a
sua esposa a sua namorada a sua ex
companheira ou a próxima que ele terá
e nós fizemos esses homens com a gente e
aulas dialogada debates de conversa
falando sobre vários assuntos e
sexualidade quando a mulher flamel é não
ea insistência pode ser um estupro
falando sobre masculinidade o homem
também chora o homem sensível
você pode expressar seus sentimentos
sobre a cop droga
noventa por cento dos homens estão sob
efeito de álcool e droga
falamos também sobre masculinidade sobre
o machismo as injustiças que são
cometidas contra a mulher
se você tem uma lei para proteger uma
mulher é que as relações estão desiguais
e alimenta equilibrar nos danos contra
os homens mas sim a favor dos direitos
das mulheres e eles serão os menos
maiores beneficiados
o primeiro projeto nós tivemos 75 por
cento da lesão e nenhuma incidência na
segunda edição do projeto nós tivemos 90
por cento de adesão e apenas uma
reincidência já no segundo chama a
atenção
tivemos investimentos
empresas privadas empresas públicas
tivemos palestrantes internacionais
falando com esses homens e deixamos um
legado
o projeto virou lei agora é obrigatório
fazer o projeto entabulando a fé
conversar com esses homens e como dar
visibilidade à polícia com as mídias
sociais
eu comecei a postar ações positivas de
combate à violência contra a mulher
projetos decisões judiciais as ações dos
órgãos públicos nos projetos para a
prevenção de combate à violência contra
a mulher e deu sucesso deu resultado
comecei a receber várias denúncias
várias pessoas querem trabalhar
voluntariamente nos projetos e
conseguimos ter uma grande visibilidade
e eu acho que tanto é verdade que o e
mail quase oito milhões de jovens quando
do sobre o tema violência contra a
mulher nas provas nas faculdades tiveram
cinco das principais capas de revista
falando sobre o tema tiver os jovens
meninas indo para as ruas se declarando
feministas sem nenhum tipo de vergonha
lutando pelos nossos direitos
aliás no tendo não conquistando direitos
nossos e já foram conquistados fazendo
valer seus direitos
o que nós não queremos retrocesso nós
não vamos mais tem nosso tian 17 anos e
foram tornadas nós queremos sutiãs mais
bonitos nem queremos assistir
nós queremos é a nossa liberdade de
escolha ea segunda forma que eu entendi
dar visibilidade aos projetos
foi a corrida que é o que me dar
condicionamento físico e me ajuda a
encarar essa violência do dia-a-dia
relatado foi indirectamente através do
esporte nós reunimos uma causa social
com alguma coisa que transforma a
realidade das pessoas e tem visibilidade
fizemos um primeiro treino eu mesmo
tempo pessoas que correm em que gosta de
causas sociais
no primeiro treino nós somos
eles 80 mulheres da comunidade
nós tínhamos só água e bananas também
sentidas pelo texto do meu marido mas
isso evoluiu em macho de 2015 agora nós
tivemos três mil pessoas nas ruas
correndo lado a lado pelo fim da
violência contra a mulher
trezentos mil reais de investimentos e
ainda conseguimos investir em projetos
de ongs que se dedicam aos projetos de
prevenção e combate à violência contra a
mulher e no ano que vem tem mais cinco
capitais cinco corridas espero vocês lá
você sabe que está no caminho certo
quando as pessoas mais velhas se admiram
e tinha cláudia quando as pessoas da sua
geração de um visado achou engraçada mas
estão do seu lado e te apoia quando as
pessoas mais jovens são sempre de boa tá
tudo muito bom mas quando dá ruim andar
o problema ela se chama para resolver
que tem como referência e ainda tira um
self com você um dia eu achei mulher
chegou pra mim na promotoria de justiça
e me disse o seguinte doutora processo
já acabou
ele já foi condenado mas eu preciso de
uma ajuda da senhora doutora por favor
me ajuda a voltar a viver naquele
momento eu percebi que eu só precisava
de uma vaga em creche de um atendimento
psicológico de trabalho e de uma
cirurgia reparadora para melhorar se a
crise da facada que ela tinha levado e
assim não é diferente com outras
mulheres que já têm os processos
julgados mas que precisam da nossa ajuda
para resgatar a autoestima dessas
mulheres
nós chegamos aqui com um pé atrás mas
foi o alerta foi um despertar essa frase
foi dita pelos homens que fizeram
projeto e esses homens carinhosamente o
léo me chamaram minha qualidade
de dama de fé mas quem fala para vocês
hoje assim não é uma pessoa de fé é uma
mulher é uma mulher sujeita a qualquer
tipo de violência física psicológica
sexual patrimonial outro lado por favor
o livro doado quantas mulheres nós temos
aqui coisas nós sofre algum tipo de
violência é cada três mulheres no brasil
uma sofre algum tipo de violência
a cada 12 segundos uma mulher sofre
algum tipo de violência no brasil
o que nós estamos fazendo para diminuir
esse eu sou neta filha filha da regina
irmã domitila e mãe da família mas eu
também me sinto né de muitas donas e
leffe filha de muitas marias da pele
a irmã de muitas machos de muitas taís
araújo e mãe de muitas valentinas tinha
uma menina que tinha um sonho era viver
uma vida livre de qualquer tipo de
violência
ela conseguiu ela transformou a vida
dela ea vida de muitas mulheres
mas ela não quer cumprir a obrigação ela
quer virar lei o trabalho dela é muito
mais do que dá voz a essas mulheres
o trabalho dela é fazer com que essas
vozes sejam ouvidas
vocês estão ouvindo a minha voz
obrigada